Susan Daniels: Welcome back this is day two in the morning, part two, in the morning, we left off with group decision making techniques and we still have a couple more to talk about.
Susan Daniels: But I want to pick back up with multi criteria decision analysis, you may see this one as a test question answer, something you can choose from.
Susan Daniels: It is used frequently, it is one of the most popular objective ways, you know to be a political for you to remain neutral, not to have to facilitate.
Susan Daniels: Just to objectively collect information and then how the process design itself come to an objective recommendation.
Susan Daniels: And the way that it works is pretty much just creating a table, if you will.
Susan Daniels: And you put your solutions in the columns let's say for easy to example that everyone can relate to you're going to try to buy a new phone okay.
Susan Daniels: And are or a new computer or a new car and you list the different.
Susan Daniels: options that you've kind of narrowed it down to right you've gone out and done some market research and you've got about two or three solution options that you can choose from, and in your rose you put the different features Okay, of what you want to evaluate it by.
Susan Daniels: And then you create this matrix right, and the second thing that you create once you have the solution options and the decision criteria that you've been evaluated by Okay, and the Rose.
Susan Daniels: You negotiate with everyone who's going to give you input, who has voting or authority to decide, you get them to agree to what does this scale mean if you're going to use a scale of one to five, are you going to use poor fare good great are you what are you going to use as your decision.
Susan Daniels: of how you evaluate scale of one to five, one to 10 high moderate low doesn't matter but everybody has to agree to it okay um hey I see stuff going on in.
Susan Daniels: The chat let's not be talking about rock paper scissors and let's keep the chat just two topics, one of the problems we had yesterday is we got a lot of stuff going on that wasn't relevant to the.
Susan Daniels: The topic and it made made it hard for us to make this tool what it is and conversation between the instructor in the students okay peer to peer let's kind of keep that to just relevant to the topic being discussed.
Susan Daniels: kind of being a you know, a teacher here if I will but let's let's kind of control this chat feature, so that everyone can benefit from it.
Susan Daniels: Sorry, to call you out TIM on that one my apologies um so this multi criteria decision analysis let's um.
Susan Daniels: let's we've got our choices across the top and columns we've got the decision factors that we're going to evaluate a by on the Rose we've agreed on what the scale means of how we're going to evaluate it.
Susan Daniels: And then you in essence distributed to the decision makers and much like your dot voting, you can have really bias people that only want.
Susan Daniels: One solution to be chosen and they can rate that the highest points and everything else trash right well that's only one person's opinion right and they got it they got a weight against everybody else's.
Susan Daniels: oftentimes the first round, all it does is eliminate one of the options Okay, the lowest scored one and you do this, maybe two or three times well from the solutions we have available now how would you score it.
Susan Daniels: And if you have someone consistently being very biased, you can say look you're becoming an outlier and you need to really.
Susan Daniels: Get back and you're looking at both of these subjectively because the other one may very well when and if it does.
Susan Daniels: You need to tell me where you've got concerns and where you do think it will work for you, so you can do some.
Susan Daniels: mentoring, with your people, but that's behind the scenes when to look at the results, the Multi criteria decision analysis is probably a project managers best friend in trying to do group decisions when you've got a lot of.
Susan Daniels: Shall we say political powerhouses that you're working with and you.
Susan Daniels: need to remain neutral and not try to influence the outcome because, quite honestly, you get paid the same if they go this way or they go that way you just want to know what they want your job is to remain neutral and offer an objective solution okay.
Susan Daniels: Okay, yes, thanks, Chris you can also add weights, to the ranks in the matrix let's say that you consider battery life more important than um.
Susan Daniels: I don't know some other feature that may be available on this device, you can add weights to those when you build your matrix so that some things are worth more than others.
Susan Daniels: I usually say if we're buying a car that color isn't going to be as important as having power steering something like that.
Susan Daniels: This um i've this has been a basis for a test question in the past, I don't know if it's still in the test question bank but um this.
Susan Daniels: type of voting information has been in the curriculum from pmi since i've been teaching and that's been for several additions of the pen Bach so just the fact that it continues to be in here I wouldn't just gloss over.
Susan Daniels: This it's important to understand there's different ways of trying to reach an answer.
Susan Daniels: Unanimity simply says it's got to be unanimous, everybody has to agree we're not going to move forward, until we have complete unanimous consensus right.
Susan Daniels: majority says look we're just going to go with majority rules more than 51% that's the direction we're going to go.
Susan Daniels: Plurality simply says we've got multiple solutions and we're going to go with the one that gets the most votes Okay, and you have more losers that way, but it is a way to move rapidly.
Susan Daniels: Sometimes it's good enough for example and you've got you know, a bunch of people in a car you're trying to decide where to go to lunch get a lot of different offers or ideas.
Susan Daniels: And you go with the one that gets the most votes I can do that right, and you get the most poor people who want to eat that kind of food right that's plurality and action.
Susan Daniels: um.
Susan Daniels: Of let me see.
Susan Daniels: Delphi Delphi technique um Delphi technique is literally just asking a series of questions when you have you have some body, where you've got a lot of outliers you know you've got perhaps say i'm single.
Susan Daniels: outlier but it turns out to be the Vice President of the company and they think that something can be done to this level of.
Susan Daniels: Excellence or it can be done in this time period we use the Delphi method to bring on outliers into consensus right closer to consensus on, you have to have total agreement.
Susan Daniels: Before you can lock it into your schedule lock it into your budget lock it into your quality standards.
Susan Daniels: So what you do is you send out on please ask me for me how long you think something will take right and you get the first round and answers and sure enough.
Susan Daniels: You know you've got this outlier this Vice President thinks something can be done just in miraculous time period you got everybody else going well, really is going to take about three weeks, not one.
Susan Daniels: Well, the way you ask the question is, please provide an estimate and an explanation to support your estimate or justification for your estimate you as the Delphi method is done with only one person i'm basically facilitating it and everyone else doing it anonymously.
Susan Daniels: You collect that information you then review it package, it and send it back out going in the email read something like please find below the results from the first round of the Delphi survey, as you will see, we have a strong.
Susan Daniels: variance in this estimate, but please read the explanations provided by your peers in our by the contributors well what happens is now the.
Susan Daniels: The group is thinking is only take three weeks is Delphi technique and agile method, no, it is a project management method.
Susan Daniels: um, it is a group consensus building methodology.
Susan Daniels: The people who thought is going to take three weeks understand now why the Vice President, I think this should take a week and it gets some better position to answer them.
Susan Daniels: And now the Vice President gets to see why there's so many people who think is going to take three weeks ah OK so.
Susan Daniels: When you send out the results you also ask them to please re estimate based upon the information that has been provided in the from the first round.
Susan Daniels: Well, which you see in the second round is it moves a lot closer together Okay, and this is the way for people who don't have much voice or influence our access to senior leadership.
Susan Daniels: To voice would they need to voice upline okay and senior leadership now has a way of hearing what they don't want to call a meeting over, but still get that information and they can adapt their perspective.
Susan Daniels: they'll find mothers i'm really, really helpful in project management okay.
Susan Daniels: The difference between majority a plurality majority is simply if you've got 10 people.
Susan Daniels: On It only takes six to have the majority so six votes is enough to say, this is the solution that we're going to go for.
Susan Daniels: Plurality says we're going to go with the solution that gets the most votes, even though it might only one get four votes and the other ones get three and three right it's the one that has the most votes.
Susan Daniels: When you have more than two more than two solutions.
Susan Daniels: Okay.
Susan Daniels: Please, if you are not familiar with the idea of what mind mapping is or what mind mapping tools are I strongly encourage you to Google different software programs and tinker with different mind mapping software.
Susan Daniels: hey, it is a great way to organize information by free association and allows you to change how things are grouped.
Susan Daniels: And categorized and tagged to each other with just a simple move them a mouse much harder to do in.
Susan Daniels: spreadsheets and tables there's columns and rows and insertion in my mapping, you can just open up a like a bubble and tag it to what it belongs to it's very fluid, if you are a non linear thinker.
Susan Daniels: Okay mind mapping is the tool, you have been waiting for, if you're a linear thinker stick with your on your spreadsheets they work for you, but there's there's a whole host of us out here, that is not the best method for us to try to get our thoughts across into organize.
Susan Daniels: Another thing that is similar to our mind mapping is affinity diagrams and in depth affinity diagrams affinity simply is a word that means affiliated associated similar to okay.
Susan Daniels: A diagram that simply group stuff together, so it does right, it can group your requirements together by any means you want so.
Susan Daniels: These are two data representation tools and you need to know when you see my mapping, or you see affinity diagrams is talking about grouping and organizing information Okay, which would the very much about your scope Okay, and your work breakdown structure.
Susan Daniels: Okay, so i've got another another.
Susan Daniels: Video for you, but i'm going to have to stop it at a certain point and started again at another point so just bear with me as I go through that with you give me a moment to set it up.
Susan Daniels: Good to 19 let's make sure that i'm.
Susan Daniels: I want to make sure i'm sharing the audio and the video with you.
Susan Daniels: share.
Susan Daniels: Okay, sharing okay turn the volume up.
Susan Daniels: Here let's go.
In this topic you'll learn about some of the tools and techniques, you can use while collecting requirements for your project.
Throughout all of your activities of course you'll use the first technique expert judgment that of your own and those around you who have the expertise you require for your work.
One group of techniques, you can use to collect project requirements is data gathering some data gathering techniques include brainstorming which we will cover in detail in a moment.
They also include conducting interviews with stakeholders subject matter, experts and people who've worked on related projects.
These people can help you identify what features and functions a product or service should have most often you'll hold one on one interviews, you can ask the person you interview a set of questions you've prepared and any other questions that come up and you record the person's responses.
Focus groups another data gathering technique or a less formal way of collecting project requirements.
In a group of stakeholders and subject matter experts you guide an interactive discussion about what a proposed product or service must deliver.
This can help you find out what expectations, the stakeholders have usually a focus group include stakeholders with a similar role or perspective.
You use the group to collect requirements focused on a specific aspect of a project like the design of a product or the technical requirements, it must meet.
And questionnaires let you gather responses to a set of written questions using these tools, you can get information from a large number of people quickly.
and information gathered in this way can usually be evaluated using statistical analysis.
You could use an online questionnaire, for instance, to find out which features customers across the country value most in a new car, but it probably wouldn't be a good idea to use a questionnaire to find out what requirements executive managers in your company have for a new car model.
Benchmarking is another data gathering technique and involve studying how other organizations, create similar products and identifying best practices and new innovations.
One thing.
Susan Daniels: And then we jump to.
reef.
filmmaking is another key technique decision making methods can include voting and multi criteria decision analysis.
voting methods include unanimity majority plurality and autocratic voting in unanimity, everyone agrees with the decision in a majority more than 50% of the group Members agree on the decision.
A plurality indicates, of all the choices one decision has the highest number of votes, even if a majority is not achieved, for instance, if there are three choices, the top choice may represent 45% of votes, while the second and third choices represent 29% and 26% respectively.
In an autocratic method or dictatorship one person decides for the group, this might sound bad, but in certain situations it is appropriate for instance a risk manager may decide that a particular product feature will not be included because it adds too much risk.
Multiple criteria decision analysis involves a systematic approach, using a matrix to determine the best decision.
Another technique you use to collect requirements includes data representation techniques such as affinity diagrams and mind mapping.
And affinity diagram can be used to classify large amounts of data and numbers into groupings, so the information is easier to review and analyze.
A mind map is useful because it brings together a lot of ideas it groups these ideas visually to make it clear how they relate or differ.
At the Center of the map is the problem to be solved as you think of ideas you build branches out from the Center each branch groups related ideas at the end of each branch you get too specific ideas that develop for more general ones.
When you're collecting project requirements from a group of stakeholders, the specific ideas you want to get to at the end of each branch are project requirements.
interpersonal.
And team skills or another group of techniques.
Susan Daniels: So hopefully that video um provided you some clarification on what mind mapping is it's a very, very useful tool, so if you haven't explored it please go for it, I did see a question that floated through on.
Susan Daniels: Do we need to know the Delphi method and the answer is yes, because you may see it as one of the test question answers.
Susan Daniels: Which tools would you might be using in this situation, and you need to know the Delphi is about building consensus and group decision making and is that applicable or not applicable in this situation they've described.
Susan Daniels: The the pmt exam is very much scenario based and part of it is knowing what tools to use.
Susan Daniels: Secondly, you need to know Delphi because it's an extremely useful technique as a project manager and trying to get a large group of people to work together towards a common good it's a way to remain neutral and a political, but still move your project forward it's a very helpful technique.
Susan Daniels: Other tools that we use in trying to organize the information is something called a context diagram.
Susan Daniels: And this really is just organizing the group by one of which it is applicable Okay, you have affinity diagrams was just roughly group things on one factor right you put things together on one factor.
Susan Daniels: The context diagram say how do these groups relate to each other right it's more about the relationships between them that's the context.
Susan Daniels: You can find different examples of context diagrams just need to know that it's a helpful tool when you're trying to organize a large volume of information, this is one way of doing it.
Susan Daniels: Now we're really getting into on.
Susan Daniels: The requirements part and requirements is give me a second on.
Susan Daniels: Requirements documentation is part of your scope management plan.
Susan Daniels: It is, but we keep it organized in something like a configuration management system.
Susan Daniels: Because now we've gone from Charter, which was hypothetical and and kind of the visioning of what they wanted it was just the big idea.
Susan Daniels: And then we started talking about trying to organize it by figuring out what work life cycle of the project, we were going to use to try to get from current state to future state.
Susan Daniels: And then we started really going out and collecting information how am I going to collect this information, what tools, am I going to use to collect this information well now we're getting to where we're literally know what.
Susan Daniels: What what people we're going to be working with and what features and functions we're trying to create now we need to get into another level of granularity.
Susan Daniels: And that's collecting the requirements.
Susan Daniels: It did I do the right.
Susan Daniels: Ladies and gentlemen, we see, I may have missed shown you give me a second technical.
Susan Daniels: Here or here let's see I I did the right thing playlist.
Susan Daniels: For today.
Susan Daniels: Looking at my other chart i'm.
Susan Daniels: Ladies and gentlemen, give me a second.
Susan Daniels: We need to look at something.
Susan Daniels: For effective requirements gathering, we did do that okay.
Susan Daniels: Just needed to double check my apologies guys.
Susan Daniels: wanted to make sure the for effective requirements gathering stop, and there are several Thank you okay.
Susan Daniels: My apologies I suffered from a head cold and just wanted to make sure I had given you the videos that you needed to have.
Susan Daniels: One we're moving into collecting requirements and we're talking about different kinds of requirements, it can have on.
Susan Daniels: This slide is very important is about types of requirements and I will tell you that there's a lot of detail on this slide.
Susan Daniels: And it's going to take a while to consume it, but the key things you need to be able to do for the exam is to recognize different types.
Susan Daniels: And if they gave you an example, would you recognize it as a quality example requirement or a stakeholder example requirement.
Susan Daniels: For a transition and I usually spend a long time talking about transition readiness requirements and solution function and non function, and we do have a slide specifically on on function coming up next the transition on.
Susan Daniels: readiness requirements are probably the ones that are least developed by new project managers new project managers frequently will be so focused on delivering the thing that they have to deliver and have all needed all the.
Susan Daniels: Measures of success that they oftentimes haven't figured out what it takes to have a successful transition to the recipient parties have this new thing this new change and are they ready to receive it, and can they maintain it.
Susan Daniels: So there's a lot involved in.
Susan Daniels: Doing smooth transition is sort of the differentiator between new project managers and or or or experienced project managers they've learned how important it is to.
Susan Daniels: Have that smooth happy face in the room, when you go to da release of the final product and the people who are getting and are like yeah we're all ready to have it now, as opposed to.
Susan Daniels: they're going yeah thanks a lot buddy really appreciate you dump in this on us right when they're not really ready so it's very important that you.
Susan Daniels: Add into your scope development any training requirements any additional staffing that may be necessary Okay, I have done projects where we literally had to hire another person in the recipient organization to be able to be the maintainer of the new process.
Susan Daniels: And the the operations team that will that received it was like you can pay for that out of project dollars.
Susan Daniels: And I can go I can pay for it out of project dollars until the new operating year and then you've got to sustain it from there.
Susan Daniels: And they're like that's negotiable that gives them plenty of lead time to go through the entire budgeting cycle build it in and sustain your project.
Susan Daniels: it's never good to deliver what was asked for, and then it sort of just melt down or get abandoned okay anybody's ever experienced that it's not a good reputation builder you want to make sure you have great transition.
Susan Daniels: Is a transition for post go live support activity exactly it is making sure that it is effectively and well integrated into it so just because you go alive doesn't mean you're done Okay, you want to make sure that they are.
Susan Daniels: ready to let go of the support that that.
Susan Daniels: they're ready to let go they're like Yes, this is fully operational fully integrated so let's talk about some of the non functional requirements, so you develop the thing but did you build in okay some of.
Susan Daniels: These requirements to keep it sustained is it going to be able to build you know to scale and capacity for the as the organization grows right.
Susan Daniels: What is your backup plan for this Okay, these are the non functional requirements.
Susan Daniels: we're moving on how to the The thing that has to function of the unique deliverable of the product has to function, but how do you keep a sustained.
Susan Daniels: All of this, so when we're doing scope management, we have literally two plants, we have the master scope management plan and a sub component of that is your requirements management plan.
Susan Daniels: Excuse me.
Susan Daniels: Again, this is a a document that you prepare and send to your senior leadership and you're really trying to tell them.
Susan Daniels: How you're going to organize it what's your what kind of requirements you're going to go forth in and collect again by what kind i'm talking about all of these.
Susan Daniels: What kind of requirements are you going to go collect they might have an area of concentration, you didn't even think about.
Susan Daniels: But the fact you knew to even think of the non functional and the transitional ones it's just going to differentiate you from those that have got their project management professional certification and those that are still just trying to wing it out there Okay, it is.
Susan Daniels: These plans and having the robustness of them is what you're trying to learn here is what makes you the professional in the industry, you know to do these right.
Susan Daniels: I want to talk to you about a particular tool that has been in existence for many, many, many, many years it is called the requirements traceability matrix and it has this very important purpose.
Susan Daniels: It is one is the beginning of your configuration management system, I repeat your requirements traceability matrix when you start to build it's usually a table it's usually in a spreadsheet capability our data software data management software.
Susan Daniels: But we start with the requirements traceability matrix and then you continue to build out on it to make your configuration management system more on that to come.
Susan Daniels: What I want you to notice in this is a couple of core or key requirements in this matrix, not only do we have, what is the requirement right, but you have to tie it to a business need opportunity goal or objective.
Susan Daniels: Think of it this way, every requirement must be justified.
Susan Daniels: A must be tied to what your projects objectives are is going to save money is going to improve efficiency is going to lower cost is going to improve customer satisfaction.
Susan Daniels: is going to what major objective overarching objective from your charter that your project said measure my success overarching Lee the whole thing by these criteria, those are the criteria that you're using Okay, how is it going to move the business forward right the greater good.
Susan Daniels: It is not an individual departments need, it is the projects need okay so here's what happens to this document.
Susan Daniels: You you you, you may or may not have time to document every one of the requirements, you may have an assistant project manager certified associate project manager a business analyst business analysts are very good at requirements management in trade collection it's kind of their forte.
Susan Daniels: But what you want to do with this is once you've got all your requirements collected or even a couple of times in periods of you know, reporting cycles.
Susan Daniels: send this matrix upline sorted, you want to sort all of these so that you can clearly identify what business need that requirement fills and if you find the justification that's provided is kind of weekly written very poorly written not closely tied or not provided at all.
Susan Daniels: You want to sort those to the top and you want to draw this to the attention of your sponsor.
Susan Daniels: and your sponsors i'm going to go Okay, what do I have here, and you go well, this is the alignment of all of the requirements to the business needs and.
Susan Daniels: Opportunities and objectives of this project and, as you can see i've sorted to the top a couple of that don't have any justification and a couple that I think are somewhat poorly.
Susan Daniels: explained, I just wanted to bring this to your attention because, once this is approved.
Susan Daniels: All of this will be included in the cost and in the schedule and will you know basically help build out the baseline of this project, so I want to make sure that you're only building what you think is most important okay.
Susan Daniels: Now a couple of things are going to happen one you've just given your sponsors, the opportunity to kind of.
Susan Daniels: really make sure they're not paying for anything they don't want to pay for Okay, and really look at how things are being justified.
Susan Daniels: To they're going to see where some people do something called sandbagging or gold plating these are expressions for.
Susan Daniels: adding more than necessary okay kind of piling on seeing if the project will pay for something that they did they want done but they don't have the money in their operating budget to do in anyone relate to that.
Susan Daniels: So this gives your leadership, a chance to kind of deal with that political dynamic.
Susan Daniels: So they can respond in a couple of ways, once they have this powerful tool in front of them now, you are a political, you are neutral you this is fact based decision making.
Susan Daniels: i've got these requirements, this is how they tie some do some don't so much, please let me know if this is everything that you want to pay for and.
Susan Daniels: So they are going to either strike some requirements that are not well justified or not well i'm done.
Susan Daniels: They might recognize who that's from and go there, they go again, thank you, I appreciate you give me a chance to catch this before it gets very far i've gotten a couple thank yous before.
Susan Daniels: or they are going to go good to know you know i've got a meeting with so and so.
Susan Daniels: in about two hours and I need their support on something I think I now have a quid pro quo or a tit for tat he now has something he can trade.
Susan Daniels: i'll build this into my project if you help me with this right, this is a very powerful document, and it is a tool that project managers have used for many, many, many years.
Susan Daniels: Encourage you become familiar with it and start your project management practice with a template that you have adapted from any example you pull off line hey.
Susan Daniels: I see some questions scrolling through so let's stop the chat for a moment, let me see if I can answer some questions let's see can you as sponsors sponsors is a person who has the money to pay for the project.
Susan Daniels: Can the arms requirements traceability matrix help prevent scope creep it doesn't prevent scope creep because you it's, this is what defines the scope.
Susan Daniels: Anything after this okay is considered scope creep this is locking in all of the requirements that we are now going to build into our schedule in our budget okay it, it is the core foundation of the scope okay anything on the on that is scope creep a good question though okay.
Susan Daniels: Can you see.
Susan Daniels: I don't know how to it's kind of a yellow we I see that it's blurry some of your comment is blurry it's a yellow we background, so my apologies, and that might be adding to the blur um.
Susan Daniels: let's see.
Susan Daniels: Are the templates you show us the same all around the PM Community um these are just samples, these are example, these are not valid way to do it, are racing you know very specific one REC I stands for wps very specific.
Susan Daniels: store how you write a user story very specific.
Susan Daniels: This is just a general example you can find others, but what is absolutely foundational to requirements traceability matrix regardless, is what is the requirement and how does it, how is it justified and you should almost always have where did it come from right where did it come from.
Susan Daniels: Some of these others are all going to be what what requirement, what is it tied to as far as a deliverable that's great on that some of these others are going to be unique to your project in sometimes to your industry.
Susan Daniels: Okay um we're at the point now that I need to we're not going to have another breaks, we took one right at the top of the hour, so we're going to go on until i'm.
Susan Daniels: Probably 1230 let's see when's my next break.
Susan Daniels: it's going to be from 1215 to 1230 so hang in there with me.
Susan Daniels: remember how we talked about having on your project.
Susan Daniels: description your general project description okay that's what you're going to use to kind of.
Susan Daniels: orientate your your project on all of your your reporting documentation your performance reports sort of when they pick up your packet it's like oh yeah that's what this project is all about, well, we write a project scope statement.
Susan Daniels: And it really very much borrows information from that first draft.
Susan Daniels: of your project description, but your project scope statements going to also include some elements of what it doesn't include.
Susan Daniels: Right you're going to be very clear about what it doesn't we're not going to use this client group we're not going to include this geographic location not going to use this product line it's very clear about what it does and doesn't do.
Susan Daniels: And it also includes how you're going to measure success, but your project scope statement is one of the elements that you ultimately produce when you are trying to write your master project management plan your your scope management plan.
Susan Daniels: um so to do that, let me see.
Susan Daniels: Can I define scope creep yes go creep is when you have additional work done without any additional time or resources provided.
Susan Daniels: Scope creep is when you've got people working burning time and burning burning money and resources without the authorization to do so, and this happens when good people are trying to do good work for a good reason but they just don't have the authority to do so okay.
Susan Daniels: what's the difference between scope creep and gold plating ah excellent question so scope creep happens after you lock in all of your requirements.
Susan Daniels: gold plating is when you're collecting requirements and they're trying to get more than what is necessary to achieve the objectives of the project gold plating happens, while you're developing requirements scope creep happens after the requirements are locked and loaded.
Susan Daniels: Okay, where does the justification go well, and this one, this should be a very large much larger on the justification would go in this column Okay, but it would be a much larger column, the first slide purposes it got basically scrunched.
Susan Daniels: here's another one of those let's get back to so.
Susan Daniels: This is just a reiteration of what we've covered earlier, as well as the on the video that we watched but now it's all documented in one slide for your convenience okay.
Susan Daniels: So when we talk about how we're developing our scope and collecting our requirements we have to do something called product analysis.
Susan Daniels: And, just like we have different types of requirements that we would need to take into consideration the stakeholders requirements, the functional and non functional requirements, the transition requirements okay.
Susan Daniels: This is for your whole product, this is getting right into the product itself Okay, this is going deep into product analysis, what do I have to have for this thing that i'm producing to be effective.
Susan Daniels: i'm not going to read you the whole slide you guys are.
Susan Daniels: fully competent of doing that I just want you to know that, just like you have different types of requirements in general okay and product requirements are only one that we've built out product requirements into subsets which is this slide set helpful.
Susan Daniels: Okay.
Susan Daniels: Good question john if you add scope creep requirement via change request, can you get authorization of money.
Susan Daniels: that's how you get authorization and money is to offer a formal change request this is traditional waterfall plan days methodology.
Susan Daniels: If you see scope creep happening, you need to stop it, because they're burning resources and time but have them submit a formal change request.
Susan Daniels: get it approved, and then they can pick up where the work is if it doesn't get approved because it shouldn't have been happening in the first place Okay, then it never gets approved and they you've stopped.
Susan Daniels: The bleeding of time and money, but if it does get approved Okay, then you're back in good graces because it was a requirement that was missed and everybody agrees, it was missed, and we do need to do it, but now you have approval to formal change control.
Susan Daniels: um.
Susan Daniels: Okay, so why is it so important to add what we're not going to do, into the scope statement if it's not in there it's not getting done.
Susan Daniels: because certain projects are really desirable and a lot of divisions want it to happen to them to them to right.
Susan Daniels: And you need to make it pretty clear from the beginning, this is really only for these guys right now right.
Susan Daniels: This this group is going to experience this process enhancements this improvement for now right right kind of like you want to make it clear from the beginning you're authorized only to do this.
Susan Daniels: Right, because otherwise you might need to deal with political influencing people trying to get you to expand your scope.
Susan Daniels: And you haven't defined from the beginning with your your sponsors what it's not going to do you want the guardrails up for your protection, so that you can defer them, not as a formal change request right to add them to it.
Susan Daniels: This this project you're working on currently in flight is going to go down this path and work only on this until otherwise directed crane.
Susan Daniels: You got it, they want to join it they've got to go through formal change requests and probably come up with the money which they don't have most nine times out of 10.
Susan Daniels: So they then have to wait for the next opportunity to have the project run so it's really for your protection for your safe guard, but if you don't do it for every project just the ones where there's a lot out of me to me to wanting to happen.
Susan Daniels: Are there any easy ways to understand when scope creep requires a revisit of the project charter we're not going to revisit the project charter that was just the the.
Susan Daniels: The.
Susan Daniels: abstract articulation of the project, if you have scope creep on you use formal change request to get it.
Susan Daniels: approved, so I think i've kind of already answered that one.
Okay.
Susan Daniels: Yes, Susan is there a project scope statement you mentioned co authored with a sponsor or is it done as closely by the pm, and then endorsed by the sponsor and steering committee.
Susan Daniels: Okay, good question, so the Charter is that we use the Charter on that's that conversation with our sponsor with the PM to kind of get them in the same you know headspace of what they're envisioning it to be, and to do and not do.
Susan Daniels: Once you um i've done a lot of collection of requirements and you've got to really even understand what solution options you're going to recommend and you're going to go with then you're in a position to write the scope statement.
Susan Daniels: So the scope statement is actually crafted by the project manager Okay, but all of the collection, requirements and deciding what solution options we're going to go with to.
Susan Daniels: group decision making all that's done with the sponsors and all the key stakeholders so ultimately you'll arrive at the scope statement as at the end of a lot of team effort, but you personally right the scope statement.
Okay.
Susan Daniels: So this is just your guideline for on developing a scope statement.
Susan Daniels: And then let's see where we're going i'm just looking at my my notes okay we're going to be in good shape so we're going to.
Susan Daniels: go through and change the subject next about so we've collected all this remember I introduce work breakdown structure spend some time talking about that it now we're going to really get into it.
Susan Daniels: decomposition you need to recognize that that tool is consistently applied when doing scope development okay decomposition in scope, management, you should in your mind have it seared that tool is used in scope Okay, because we are breaking down the work we're decomposing the work.
Susan Daniels: There are a couple of ways that you can lay out a work breakdown structure.
Susan Daniels: If you are a visual person Okay, and you are someone who works well on non litter Lee like with mind maps and likes to see things visually.
Susan Daniels: You can do your work breakdown structure like this okay now please don't make is a kind of six Sigma method, so they are this acronym stands for define measure analyze improve and control they're just using this as an example.
Susan Daniels: But I want you to extrapolate from here that this could be.
Susan Daniels: Sales marketing facilities customer service.
Susan Daniels: Finance Okay, this could be different geographic regions these could be different product lines different customer basis, however, at the top level, you want to start to break your project apart, this is the level you started at and then let's say from.
Susan Daniels: Each one of these areas you're going to need different deliverables then that's where you're going to put each of these work packages think things are work package is an observable measurable i'm.
Susan Daniels: In result, something that you can point to and demonstrate that it is done Okay, it is a result right a work package, it can be a tangible or non tangible result, but it is something that you can assign and you can verify that it has been completed.
Susan Daniels: So.
Susan Daniels: i'm going to introduce a concept to you called a limit for one thing.
Susan Daniels: yeah Okay, so I want to introduce something called a rook wps dictionary.
Susan Daniels: Why a wps dictionary now for the longest time I struggled with why they call it a dictionary because.
Susan Daniels: Why would it be in project management, you would want a dictionary what dictionaries are used so that everyone has a common understanding of the words that are being used right.
Susan Daniels: So if we are talking about developing work packages, we want to make sure that these work packages, we have a very common understanding of what this work package is going to be when it's done.
Susan Daniels: So you want to be able to negotiate this right it's it's a document is going to to have a lot of the details about this word package, some of the things that are listed.
Susan Daniels: Do I create a web s for each word package in my project.
Susan Daniels: I sound like a lot of work says, many of my students want to introduce the concept, and the answer shockingly is yes, but there is an easy way to do it okay so picture, if you will.
Susan Daniels: That you have gone through the heavy lifting of collecting all the requirements to get from the current state to the desired future state okay.
Susan Daniels: And you have organized it into your work breakdown structure, you know where the work is being assigned how it's being organized you know who i'm saying is a requirement that has to be done so, you probably know, who's going to be doing the work to get it done.
Susan Daniels: So you've got your work breakdown structure you're sitting at your desk you open up.
Susan Daniels: A word file it's basically a questionnaire it's a questionnaire that says, for this work package okay assigned to accountable for right now who's accountable for it okay.
Susan Daniels: You have a description of what the word package is you, list the requirements of this work package, and then you start asking questions such as.
Susan Daniels: What resources will you need estimate the cost of those resources, can you tell me what activities, it will take to produce this work package, what are your predecessor, could you have any dependencies for your predecessor activities where the do you have any handoffs do you have any.
Susan Daniels: dependencies standalone fun another party for this work package or their risks that are associated with it.
Susan Daniels: Can you quantify those risks, can you give me a contingency response for those risks okay how am I going to measure acceptance criteria, how are we going to measure you know how are we going to measure that it means that what are the quality right.
Susan Daniels: compliance requirements on and on and on this questionnaire goes.
Susan Daniels: But it's the same questionnaire that you send out to every one of these work package accountable parties, so you open an email.
Susan Daniels: You have a standard email that basically says, please find attached, though wps dictionary I call it survey right um our questionnaire, please complete all applicable components right and return to me by.
Susan Daniels: And you save it attach the file and put it in drafts and you do this all afternoon, creating your your survey.
Susan Daniels: And once you're done building all of these questionnaire quick questionnaires for each one of the work packages and the emails are bill you just hit send send send send send and you have launched the next phase of your project I usually go and take a three day vacation.
Susan Daniels: everybody's working on, is trying to get back to you when you come back now you have all the information need to start to develop your cost estimates your schedule estimates your risk.
Susan Daniels: Identification you may find out who you need to have preferred procurement from right if you need to go out of the House, you start asking do you have preferred vendors, for your procurements.
Susan Daniels: The more robust your project management web s dictionary questionnaire is the more efficient, you are going to be in building out the rest of your master plan.
Susan Daniels: The heavy lifting on your part, is already happened right all those requirements meetings and understanding the what we are ultimately going to build right now we're going to get down to get her it on right make the master plan to get her done.
Susan Daniels: So the wps dictionary is an essential tool to be a highly effective project manager.
Susan Daniels: Are we sending the wps dictionary email to to the accountable party for that work package.
Susan Daniels: Okay um.
Susan Daniels: there's a question about trying to explain the.
Susan Daniels: FF SF SF abbreviations on the flow chart in the lower corner oh i'm.
Susan Daniels: you're ahead of this is kind of a head, all this is trying to tell you is you need to be asking about are there dependencies between different work packages.
Susan Daniels: And what kind of relationships they're going to be this this is finished, to start finish to finish start to finish, and start just start slides on that coming when we get into schedule okay.
Susan Daniels: So.
Susan Daniels: i've got.
Susan Daniels: i'm going to go ahead and respect that it's time for a break you guys have been engaged for an hour.
Susan Daniels: And when we come back we're going to continue working on the work breakdown structure and then we're going to.
Susan Daniels: spend the last hour talking about schedule okay so let's go ahead and take our break and i'll see you this one, I can only give you 10 minutes guys schedules pretty dense section, and I want to make sure I have enough time, so we got a 10 minutes break.
Susan Daniels: And i'll See you in a couple.